hi I'm Greg e I'm Johnny well here we
are again
Wonder Woman TV spots oh boy oh boy
but before we get into that we recently
launched the patreon and so many family
and friends from the real rejects have
been contributing and have become part
of the community over there so we wanted
to make a little announcer that we're
going to be starting to put exclusive
video content on the patreon that's
right with an immunity we're going to
start moving some of our our more niche
ideas yeah they're going to take movie
news we're going to do a Gregg Zaun
fanfic yeah our movie news segment is
actually you know like it's going to be
like a long movie talk yeah it's our
version of Collider boo be talking dirty
joke easy all right so if you like us
enough to hear how we feel love yeah
come on over let's face it no one really
watches our movie new segments on this
channel they only do it if you're like
if you just like us in general yes we
figure we'll give the channel towards
the reactions and reviews and the
sketches and we're going to do some cool
stuff over on patient under the folk
step one yeah the other content that
we'd like to do on here do it become a
part of the patreon are the ones who
usually watch like the segments that
don't get as many views on this channel
we also release a lot of behind the
scenes footage a lot of deleted moments
didn't seamless Monday sure yeah out
jumps and stuff so we have a lot of fun
moments that have already been going up
on the patreon so go check it out hey
John yeah
enough enough promotion for ourselves
promotional improv most the DC extended
universe God knows that's one department
they lacan thank you for who I'm keep
seeing articles about like water they're
more Wonder Woman ad well I hear the
power one is the really good one I think
we should leave that for lat go with
goddess pinky never been a mentor like
your father
[Music]
my eternity
[Music]
tough luck
whoa who is this woman
breathing my god it to the aleutian it
feel as though you're not sleepy I might
if I'm able to get a ticket okay okay
all right all right okay that was good
that was good teaser has good teaser has
a good season together together together
we are together in this room who's this
young woman with everything she's my she
and I over working together sir
[Music]
dan Francis estimate Prince Diana Prince
wicked BP 15 experience of an IMAX 3d
you know it's so interesting seeing
Chris Pine after watching half of hell
or high water laughs mm ugly text into
it if you're not I'm liking you know how
whenever you before we go into the power
one and maybe got it maybe we got a shot
of Ares their forties I'm David Thewlis
David Ulis who I think looks like the
most perverted actor in the world it's
getting like a murder-for-hire ya
laddies Nami you got pervert silly word
I can use the do it I feel about you oh
wow okay a lot of people said that about
me dude makes London LLL take the river
to know another insulting him I made
myself look significantly better for ya
oh yeah my other comment I wanted to say
was you know how whenever these male
superheroes have a female love interest
and they always seem like they base
their dull they suck most of the time
they're not anything special it's 20 how
is the first like female like big-budget
and the female superhero blockbuster
film Wonder Woman and they're making her
man look like [ __ ] bad okay you know
I don't know II just think he's just got
yeah these aren't too cool to tease on
the trays on the trailers man kicking
ass I wonder how that whole thing's
gonna play out this is like this damn
you nobody liked a namer like that looks
incredibly suspicious yeah yeah well I
hope I hope somebody sees this and takes
a pledge never hit a girl friends in the
idea cookie
power
harvesters the God created us
[Music]
and we'll fight so that we cannot fight
for them
I heard that being with Matt bidding
we'd be [ __ ] striker incident I'm not
greedy
these look pretty cool I think he's
going to defeat her in that scene
probably not going to looks like Wonder
Woman has a lot of villains in this
movie that she will have a hard time
kicking there we haven't seen Ares yet
mouth full form no no but it's Professor
Lupin
something tells me half of the movie
will feel like the other trailers and
and the like the last half will feel
like this power trailer yeah yeah like
the first half is like setup it looks
fun and games and in the last half is
when they get this like very God is oh
yeah this is huge
yeah that's the impression I'm getting
from watching it and I gotta say like in
terms of their marketing I'm glad none
of it has been like totally confusing as
to what the film will be yeah that's all
it looks like it came out of the same
name yeah yeah cuz BBS and Suicide Squad
not a rhythm part but we can all agree
the marketing was a little a little
confusing as I read a little a little
varied they look like they got images to
put over a cool songs for the trailers
and then they give away the ending yeah
I will say too that this film I do have
a lot of faith in I'm like I know the
other the other DC you found some gob
you are even some upcoming DC EU
projects give me a little concern but
this one specifically I have I have
pretty good feeling about I know I don't
know if I'm gonna bite my words on this
later I'm not going to be like damn it I
got my whole side the only thing that's
worrisome were questionable is you know
D CEUs track record in also yeah I just
really hope to get this right and I I
like what I've seen so far like I think
their directions good this isn't enough
to instill just like flat-out faith in
me I know I need to see the actual movie
especially some of the action stuff like
it's it is still at the same universe
and it has
very like smudgy color palette a fairly
grey brown color palette yeah so yeah
I'm intrigued but yeah and I hope it
turns out love it that's what I want to
do it's turning out well and I don't
think I'll be ready to settle my mind
into leopards yeah Suicide Squad was the
last straw for me and I was like now I
will be cautious until I've seen it yeah
because I'll say like with justice if
this was like the first say none of the
other movies to come out this was like
the first DC EU film
there's nothing and promotion there's
nothing in the trailers or TV spot sirs
there's not a single thing that has been
shown to me were it gets me like
questionable or worrisome about any of
it I have a lot of faith that this could
be the movie that really starts a
turning point for the DC EU yeah you
know because when they receiving a lot
of criticism while they were still
making Wonder Woman and they were
working on like really changing [ __ ] I
think this could be a cool opportunity
for them to make it wait I think this
kind of reminds me of Captain America
like the first Captain America because
it's got the throwback v it's got a
little bit of a fancy and I feel like
they could stick this with one of their
classic characters to get things back on
track that get cool for them so in the
end she gets frozen in an iceberg and
yeah Algona Ronan is greeted by Batman
okay
that was Nick dears all right guys well
subscribe to the real rejects Ruggieri
on Twitter and Instagram
he also handles all the posts on
facebook.com slash the real rejects and
facebook.com slash Blum house that's
right Blum now turn Instagram Twitter
and Instagram as well it's a social
media manager over there so anything
you're reading off of there that's most
likely his writing a lot of the time in
yeah so go check it out